Joe Biden is running for president
arguably the biggest shake-up to the
Democratic primary field since I guess
really since Bernie Sanders announced
that he was running and sort of became
instantly the front-runner and of course
up until the most recent Emerson poll
even without being an official candidate
Joe Biden was actually still in the lead
in 2020 Democratic presidential polling
and we'll get to the polling in a moment
that's not where I want to start just
hours ago former Vice President Joe
Biden announced that he is running the
76 year-old put out a three-minute video
explaining why he was running or I guess
justifying his run you can say now in
the video which you can find online we
won't play the entire thing for you
he didn't discuss policy really he
didn't really talk much about his
credentials and his experience other
than sort of by implication he focused
on the circumstances in the United
States that make him want to run he
talked about Donald Trump's fine people
on both sides statement he talked about
Trump as sort of a force that has
coalesced white nationalism and
extremism of different kinds and made a
kind of situational case for his
candidacy and for the eventual removal
of Donald Trump and Donald Trump not
super surprisingly welcoming Joe Biden
into the race with a nickname sleepy Joe
which I don't know if it's new I don't
know if he's used that one before maybe
he has I know he's used to sleepy about
other people sleepy eyed I know he's
used but it's also not very funny Donald
Trump tweeting welcome to the race
sleepy Joe I only hope you have the
intelligence long in doubt to wage a
successful primary campaign it will be
nasty you will be dealing with people
who truly have some very sick and
demented ideas but if you make it I will
see you at the capital s capital G
starting gate
so nicknames you know low energy Jeb
little Marco crooked Hillary crazy
Bernie those at least have some kind of
comedic rings sleepy Joe seems
particularly dumb because Biden's not
sleepy you can diss
with the guy on politics you can say as
I do that he's to your rights that he's
not progressive enough and I think
there's a fair critique there but
Biden's not sleepy he's a formidable
debater who could crush Trump in a
debate also not very sleepy that even
before announcing last week in an
emerson poll Biden was ahead of Trump in
a hypothetical matchup by six points the
strongest in any hypothetical matchup he
was followed I believe by Bernie versus
Trump beto versus Trump kamala versus
Trump Budaj edge and then Elizabeth
Warren sort of in that order so this is
before Biden was even a candidate had
the biggest lead in a hypothetical
matchup over Trump from the Democratic
field and then even more recently we
have a poll from this week from a
morning consult and Politico where Biden
is plus eight over Trump in a
hypothetical poll 42 to 34 of course in
that one more people sort of unsure or
undecided in that so you could argue
it's a less precise poll but the point
is sleepy Joe maybe more projection
because Trump realizes Joe Biden
politics aside which I will get to don't
destroy me yet a strong challenger to
president Trump's reelection will Becca
President Obama endorsed Joe Biden
we don't know President Obama his office
putting out a statement this morning
praising Biden but not endorsing him at
this point in time will the McCain
family endorse Joe Biden now you might
say David why why are you even asking
about that this is a really interesting
thing yesterday in advance of Joe
Biden's announcement it was reported by
the Washington Examiner that the McCain
family in other words Cindy McCain John
McCain's Widow Megan McCain John
McCain's daughter would be breaking with
the Republican Party to support Joe
Biden over Donald Trump because of the
disaster that they believe Donald Trump
to be sort of continuing the rivalry the
disagreement the bad blood between John
McCain
and Donald Trump even after John McCain
is no longer alive reported by the
Washington Examiner but immediately
denied by Cindy McCain senator McCain's
widow who knows it may be an accurate
report that is just too early and the
McCain's don't want to have that
attributed to them at this point in time
it may just be a false report I don't
know but what we do know is that there
are now two very strong candidates in
the Democratic field Bernie Sanders and
Joe Biden on the basis of polling on the
basis of polling you have seen Bernie
and Biden at the top of every single
poll you then have this next tier which
includes Budaj edge it has sort of
shifted from including Elizabeth Warren
and Camille Harris etc and then you have
a whole bunch of sort of weaker
candidates that are in the 0 to 1 and 1
to 3 percent range
you now have Biden and Bernie as the two
kind of fighting it out at the top of
these polls my politics to get to the
political analysis my politics if you're
in my audience you know if you watched
yesterday's show where I updated my
political compass results I'm to the
left of Joe Biden economically and I'm
to the left of Joe Biden on the sort of
social libertarian versus authoritarian
spectrum my politics are more like
Bernie's my politics are more like
Elizabeth Warren's there's a dose of
Andrew yang in there as well which is
why I've sort of identified them as my
top three candidates Biden is to my
right but from a practical perspective
Joe Biden is somebody that in a
one-on-one debate with Donald Trump
gives me confidence I'm not saying that
I like the policy of Joe Biden over some
of these other Democratic candidates but
what I am suggesting you do is go back
and check out the vice presidential
debates that Joe Biden had with Paul
Ryan and you will see that the younger
Paul ruie the younger than Trump Paul
Ryan the more fast-thinking
than Trump Paul Ryan did not even stand
a chance against Joe Biden I mean just
not even close
was embarrassing how Biden was toying
with Paul Ryan and Paul Ryan much
smarter much more knowledgeable much
quicker thinking than Donald Trump which
to me says that Donald Trump would get
absolutely crushed and embarrassed by
Donald Trump during - by Joe Biden
during debates but then we do it - the
political question
Biden's not super progressive by any
means we now are going to have a pretty
clear establishment versus
non-establishment dynamic developing my
guess is that Biden entering the race is
a signal more to the other would-be
establishment candidates what I mean by
that is initially it seemed maybe the
DNC and Democratic establishment is kind
of getting behind Kamala Harris
she didn't sort of grow her polling
support significantly and then the
establishment energy sort of seems to
have shifted to Pete Budaj edge and he
reportedly has been attending the stop
Bernie Democratic establishment meetings
and he's been rising in the polls but
still single digits from from what I've
seen maybe cracking 10% in one of them
Joe Biden
I believe consolidates the establishment
support the anti Bernie wing of the
Democratic Party I believe now coalesce
is behind Joe Biden if you're not super
into the sort of Bernie Warren wing of
the Democratic Party based on politics
it seems that your vote now goes behind
Joe Biden in great likelihood and we'll
have new post Biden announcement polling
may be in the middle of next week maybe
towards the end of next week
maybe there's a new poll being conducted
already and we'll have results by Monday
we'll see how that looks but Joe Biden
is representative of the old-school
Democratic Party period that has appeal
to centrist Democrats to traditional
Democrats the question is does the
Democratic primary electorate want that
in total and if they do is it something
that can defeat Donald Trump early
polling suggests
maybe it can but dynamics in these races
can change very quickly and then there's
the Hillary connection question I mean
is it in some way is Joe Biden too much
a reminder of or sort of connected to
the Hillary Clinton wing of the party in
a way that could be damaging once it
gets to the to the general election and
there are two possibilities here broadly
speaking the first possibility is
Democrats aren't nearly as progressive
as the enthusiastic support for Bernie
Sanders suggests I'm not saying I think
this is the case I'm saying this is a
possibility and Biden entering the race
is going to instantly unite the
Democratic primary electorate around Joe
Biden and against Donald Trump in a way
that is positive for Joe Biden the other
possibility is that Democratic voters
are sick of establishment politics they
associate Biden with the DNC favoring
Hillary over Bernie in 2016 and that the
Democratic primary electorate says now
it's time for something new
Biden is old-school Biden is boring
Biden is from the Hillary wing of the
party and we want something else either
way you have to get eventually to the
age of the two Democratic Party
frontrunner I'm not an identity voter I
am a issues voter and I consider
electability and sometimes identity can
be connected to that but I am NOT an
identity politics voter we have a
dynamic developing where you have 77
year old Bernie Sanders leading the
progressive wing of the Democratic Party
and 76 year old Joe Biden very quickly
coming to the front of the establishment
wing of the Democratic Party so based on
polling right now it's not my opinion
I'm just saying look at the polls and at
the fact that Bernie and Joe are leading
the Democratic primary the two most
likely faceoffs that we are to have in
2020 as of today and things can change
our 72 year old Donald Trump versus 76
year old Joe Biden they'll both be older
in 2020 of course or 72 year old Donald
Trump against 77 year old Bernie Sanders
I don't vote on identity but how were we
interpret that demographic reality about
how this is shaping up there's some good
news no matter what your view is on
Biden which is the will here won't he
run stuff is over now people who are
saying well I would vote for Bernie if
Joe doesn't run but if Joe runs I'm
probably voting for Joe we can get away
from that now so now we are going to get
sort of clearer less kind of conditional
hypothetical polling the polling now is
Joe Biden is running do you support him
and now we're gonna have to at some
point really think about Joe Biden's
politics Joe Biden originally against
gay marriage for the Patriot Act
consented to the war in Iraq and back in
2016 it was the sort of end of being
able to justify those positions by
saying times have changed
the world has changed I am a new person
I have revised my views I've had sort of
an awakening that still was maybe
passable in 2016 in 2020 the my views
have evolved and those votes sort of
made sense at the time thing I think is
a much more difficult pill to swallow
for Democratic voters and we'll have to
see what the effect is of that I don't
like as I said Joe Biden's politics are
to my right but a formidable debater and
no question that he will have an impact
on this race so it's all happening and
we will check in next week about how the
polling is affected by Joe Biden
officially entering the race I do want
to hear from you in the meantime let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show today's program
brought to you in part by Blink accom
slash Pakman blinka is a great service
that I use all the time what they do is
they take thousands of the most popular
non-fiction books including the newest
bestsellers they condense them into
15-minute audiobooks that you can listen
to and you still get the most crucial
information and insights from each book
and I've listened to a ton of books on
blink Asst I recently checked out soccer
na mcc's by Simon Cooper
we do have after all the World Cup going
on recently we also have been talking
about BS jobs and there is a great new
book of BS jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on blinka they're constantly
adding new books to the platform you
will never run out of fascinating and
critically acclaimed books to enjoy and
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink Escom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be Li NK is t.com
/pa k ma n